MOLLY GREENE: Even in a
group of remarkable students,
he's very remarkable.
HENRY SHAPIRO: My
name's Henry Shapiro,
I'm a sixth-year graduate
student in the history
department, and I'm an
Ottoman historian finishing
a dissertation on the
Ottoman-Armenian history
in the 17th century.
So the title of my dissertation
is "The Great Armenian Flight,
The Celali Revolts, and The Rise
of Western Armenian Society."
MOLLY GREENE: It's a
feat of imagination,
and creativity, and insight.
People might think that
historians simply put together
facts, but what Henry realized
for his dissertation was
that these events, the Celali
revolts, that we thought
were about one
thing, are actually
about many other things.
And there's another story
of the Celali revolt
that people hadn't understood
was there because they saw it
in a certain way.
HENRY SHAPIRO: I come
from the Bible Belt,
and I'm an Appalachian.
I grew up on the
Virginia-Kentucky border.
And when I was in
high school I was
interested in early
Christian history,
and I suppose that
that was what motivated
me to study Greek literature
as an undergraduate.
And I read the classics
as an undergraduate
and was very interested in
Homer, and Hesiod, and the New
Testament, and diverse genres
of ancient Greek literature.
And I suppose that
that's slowly what
led me to an interest
in Ottoman history,
as I move forward in the
study of Greek history
and of Christian history.
MOLLY GREENE: I
mean, Henry walked
all over Eastern Anatolia.
He used the 17th-century
chronicle as we might use a,
you know, Fodor's
Guide to Turkey,
and walked all around and up
into the mountains hiking,
sometimes for six
hours, to uncover
the physical remains of this
world that he writes about.
It's extraordinary
what he's done.
In addition to
sitting in Yerevan
and reading every manuscript
for two years, and then
he put it all together.
HENRY SHAPIRO: These
six years of Princeton
have been some of the
best years of my life,
and I'm just extremely
grateful to my professors.
When I've needed guidance,
there's been guidance.
When I've needed freedom,
there's been freedom.
When I've needed help
getting access to an archive
or traveling to Eastern Anatolia
or to Armenia, they've helped.
Princeton is very supportive
to its graduate students,
and I'll really genuinely
be grateful my whole life
for these six years.